in my family we decided the shopping
frenzy was bad for the planet bad for
our personal budgets and not that much
fun so we decided that we think our
holiday traditions holiday should be a
time for recharging our batteries four
times with friends and family for
leisure for recreation instead they're
just an absolute frenzied shopping
bonanza which just leaves us with
thousands of dollars of credit card
debts and piles of garbage we're
actually consuming stuff faster than the
planet can replenish it so we're
undermining the planets ability to
support life one of the biggest
categories is disposable stuff the
amount of disposable packaging cutlery
plates I'm cleaning appliances you know
they have toilet brushes that you use
once and then flush them like it is
insane we're throwing away now over
400,000 mobile devices a day a lot of
that ends up in landfills which are just
giant holes in the ground full of stuff
or even worse burned incinerators and
both of those cause a lot of pollution
for the air the soil that changed the
climate they pollute the communities
that live near landfills are
incinerators it's not the answer the
real answer is slow down the consumption
of stuff consumerism is different than
consumption it has to do with with when
people are trying to define their
self-worth I'm advance their social
status find meaning and identity and
community and even love through stuff
one part of consumerism that really
worries me is how we are losing all of
our other parts of our identity to that
of being a consumer the word human being
and consumer is used interchangeably as
though that is the entirety of our being
what about mother student I'm activist
citizen there's so many other aspects to
who we are and those are just being
erased in this overriding identity of
consumerism
there is another way different kinds of
traditions that actually enhance your
wellbeing rather than drain on you for
months and months to come that's less
toll on the planet it's less stolen our
personal budgets and it's more free time
to spend on the things that really
provide happiness